when i took the first call about this
case
um which was indicating that two people
may have been shot
many years ago and that they've been
buried in their own back garden
uh
part of my reaction was
surely that can't have happened can it
you know those stories that you puzzle
over
that you just can't get out of your head
well this is one of those
landscapers is a new four-part drama
from hbo and sky
it follows the true story of susan and
christopher edwards
a soft-spoken couple with a gruesome
secret
i'm caroline crampton a longtime fan of
crime fiction and the true stories that
inspire it
in this five-episode companion podcast
from hbo and sky
i'm going to take you behind the scenes
of landscapers
together we'll unpack how a team of
filmmakers adapted the chilling true
crime story for the limited series
starring olivia coleman and david thulis
[Music]
rightly there's a lot of energy
devoted to
the victims
but i think there should be a lot of
energy also devoted to
the thinking of the perpetrators
that's ed sinclair the series creator
while writing landscapers he examined
every part of the case from a backyard
burial to an obsession with film
memorabilia
and he worked with the team to bring the
story to life
kind of starts out as like a one-line
pitch but the more you put it at the
more it kind of unravels into this kind
of sprawling multifaceted incredibly
complicated exploration
as the you know actor there's always got
to be like a line you draw
because
it isn't the documentary and it isn't
a recreation it's a kind of exploration
for some of the team
adapting this story wasn't easy
as they learned about the case it seeped
in and took over
i had nightmares about it when i first
started researching not
because of the
horror so much of
the violence of what happened but like
just trying to imagine what it's like to
live
with that kind of guilt
we also talked to the real people behind
the case
the ones who experienced it firsthand
for them this story isn't a tv drama
it's their lives
i remember it was a rainy night i
actually walked to the police station
from my house it was an absolute media
circus absolutely packed to the rafters
there's probably something slightly
salacious in it
i i i like them i don't know how far i
can elaborate on that but i do
this one just fascinates me it almost
became a obsession i think
i i can't say i feel sorry for them
because i don't
let's not forget what what they've done
here is murdered two completely innocent
people
and taken them for every single penny
that they've got
[Music]
landscapers airs from december 6th on
hbo and from december 7th on sky
the landscapers podcast arrives december
6th with episodes released weekly
get ready to find out what's really
buried in the ground beneath your feet
murder is a tragic event
in the end that felt like the sort of
truest thing
that we can never actually know
the inner workings of another human
being
you